NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I'm a treasure hunter.
So your total sales
are at what?
$1.1 million.
Oh.
Whoa.
Wow.
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for...
There's a little, sweet secret
to our cinnamon rolls.
Here it is.
No!
JOHN: Whoa.
NARRATOR: ...Or they'll walk
away with nothing.
Sometimes I invest
because it's really cool.
But I'm still a shark.
So, are you holding firm
at 25%?
It doesn't add up for me.
I'm out.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
Wow.
You'd have bought
a hundred of these if they
made you look cool, Robert.
You're
a pretty good salesman.
Maybe I'm a mini-sharkette.
NARRATOR: ...They're ready to
invest using their own money.
And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
We really like your idea.
I smell
a counteroffer coming.
I'm really contemplating
screwing up Robert's offer.
Here comes
a royalty deal.
a bloodsucking offer.
Silence, please.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank is
an innovative solution
for the modern
outdoor adventurer.
Hello, sharks.
I'm Anton.
I'm Roberto.
And I'm ardy.
Our company is Oru Kayak,
and we're here seeking $500,000
for a 12% equity stake.
We all love kayaking,
but we hate all the hassle
of storing and transporting
our boats.
So what if I told you
that that kayak
folds out of this?
Wow.
WILLIS: So, a few years ago,
I set out to design a kayak
that I could literally store
inside my bedroom closet.
And to do that, I looked back
to an old childhood passion
Of mine -- Origami.
Wow!
JOHN: Oh.
That's pretty clever,
pretty clever.
So as you can see, the whole
boat unfolds pretty magically
out of a single, seamless sheet,
just like a piece of paper.
Now, this material
is extremely durable,
it's very sturdy,
and it's extremely light.
The whole boat weighs
only 26 pounds.
So as you can see, they're
inserting these rigid bulkheads,
which give the kayak
more structure.
This orange piece here,
which was the lid of the case
when I walked in,
now becomes the floorboard
of the kayak that you sit on.
Well done.
They're sealing up
the top seams.
These are the only seams
in the entire boat.
They're completely watertight,
so you're gonna stay dry,
even in rough water.
So that's a little bit
about how the kayak works.
I'm gonna hand it to Roberto
to talk about what you can do
with it.
Now, sharks, I'm a former
professional paddler,
and I've tested this
on flat lakes, big ocean waves,
and even
in Whitewater rapids.
The Oru Kayak is fast
and durable,
great for an expert-level
paddler like myself,
but it's stable,
comfortable, easy to use,
which is perfect
for beginners.
I told you a bit
about the boat.
Ardy's gonna tell you some more
about the company.
In nine months,
we launched the company,
created a manufacturing line,
and are shipping
all around the world.
Now we need a partner
to help us
scale up manufacturing
to meet the demand.
So...Who wants to jump
in the water with us?
HERJAVEC: Wow.
CORCORAN: Wow.
Remarkable.
JOHN: Good, good, good.
Excellent, excellent. Well done.
Well done, guys.
Thank you. So seriously,
you guys want to take a try,
sit in it, lift it up?
HERJAVEC: Yeah, man, yeah.
So, it's about half
the weight
of a comparable plastic
or fiberglass boat.
And it's
completely watertight?
Yeah.
Can I try it?
You can hop in.
Please. Yeah.
Is it as strong
as fiberglass?
WILLIS: Pretty strong, yeah.
We'll show you --
Pretty strong
or as strong?
As strong.
There you go.
Get out of my way.
GUTIERREZ:
Can we splash him?
You got to adjust the footrest
inside there.
You can,
just like a regular kayak.
Yeah.
I-I-I got to tell you,
it feels very, very solid.
WILLIS: It's pretty comfortable.
Yeah.
I was expecting it
to feel flimsy.
Yeah.
Not in the least.
Yeah, you'd have bought
a hundred of these
if they made you look cool,
Robert.
How many have you sold?
We sold 1,228.
Good for you.
At what price?
$1,100.
So your total sales
are at what?
$1.1 million.
Good for you.
And how have you sold them?
To who and how?
We sell primarily direct online
right now at our website,
and it's going direct
to consumer.
What does a typical kayak
sell for?
For a boat comparable in length,
size, and dimensions,
our best-selling boat
in this same range
sells for about $1,049.
So it's roughly
the same price as --
About the same
as that, yeah, so...
Is there any other collapsible
boat out there?
WILLIS: There are a few,
but they're very expensive --
Usually $4,000 or $5,000.
They're much heavier,
and they're much harder
to put together.
What's it cost you
to build one?
Right now,
it costs us $505.
Wow. That's a lot.
It is a lot, and that's why
we're looking for your money.
And what do you think is
the lowest you can get it at?
We think we can get it to $350
within the next year.
Right now it's
quite labor-intensive.
We're looking to replace
some of those labor-intensive,
handmade parts
through automation, equipment,
and assembly optimization
to just get them out
much faster, as well as cheaper.
HERJAVEC: I'm -- I'm a big
car guy. I-I love design.
What I find in the car world
is if you're unique
And -- And more beautiful,
there's a price point.
Right.
I-I'm struggling
with why aren't people
willing to pay more for it?
'cause it's beautiful.
We get both questions --
Why doesn't
this cost $500,
and why doesn't
this cost $1,500?
So what we were trying to do
is appeal
to the general population,
as well.
What's your projection
for next year?
Projection for next year
is, uh, $4 million in revenue.
You're gonna go from $1 million
to $4 million?
$1.1 million
Well, we're gonna hit --
By end of the year, we're
gonna hit $1.4 million.
Guys, I-I'll get things going.
Beautiful, beautiful.
I'm not
a big outdoors guy,
and I've never been
in a kayak in my life,
so it's not really
a great fit.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
GUTIERREZ: Okay.
Thank you.
The -- The big issue
with this deal is
I don't think 500k is enough
to automate
the manufacturing process.
Some of the equipment you need
is very expensive.
It's -- It's an interesting
product, but to me,
I-it's not developed enough
on a manufacturing and
logistics point of view
to know how this thing scales
and how fast it can scale.
For that reason, I'm out.
Thank you very much.
Thank you for your time.
I'm challenged with this,
'cause I love it,
and I want to give you
the money.
I just -- The unknown
is the manufacturing.
See, in my business, we're
really on tight margins.
Mm-hmm.
Right.
So if we can save 25 cents
on a pair of jeans,
we'll fly around the world
to do that, right?
Right. Right, right.
Right. Right.
So it's a touch too early,
and I can't help you with this.
And I'm -- I'm kicking myself,
but I'm out.
I'm not trying to push it,
but I would say I think
we've done a pretty amazing job
of getting this up -- the
manufacturing off the ground
from scratch, you know,
from a prototype.
Dealing with it
at a $1 million business
and dealing with it
at a $20 million business...
Of course. Mm-hmm.
...is night and day.
You know, I own two kayaks
that I never use. I mean...
[ laughter ]
But for some reason,
I'm dying to have this kayak.
I think it's like
a status symbol.
I really want to show off
about it.
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Yeah, yeah.
CORCORAN: And I think
that's half the sale.
It really is.
It's sexy and cool.
Yeah.
But here's the rub -- I love to
get involved with my businesses
and help them
however I can...
WILLIS: Mm-hmm.
...Other than investing
the money.
I can't imagine what I could do
With -- With this. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you very much,
yeah.
Robert?
And the only
adventure-loving guy here.
Ah.
[ laughs ]
Adventure-
and design-loving guy.
Definitely a customer.
Lot of risk
on the manufacturing side.
I think Daymond's right.
But I think you have a lot of
unanswered questions out there.
But, I got to tell you,
I-I made an investment
in a product that I just thought
was really cool --
Chordbuddy --
And we did great on it.
So sometimes I invest because,
you know, I'm a shark...
Mm-hmm.
...And I want my money back,
And it's "grrr!"
mm-hmm.
And sometimes I just think
it's really cool.
Yeah.
Right.
But I'm still a shark.
GUTIERREZ: Right.
Right.
$500,000 for 25%.
That's cutting
your valuation in half.
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Oru kayak has an offer
on the table from Robert.
$500,000 for 25%.
That's cutting
your valuation in half.
25%. All right.
So, Robert, we really love
your enthusiasm,
and we've always wanted
to have people involved
who really understand
the design behind this
on the brand value that we've --
We've -- We've created.
What do you think about 15%,
a-a seat on the board,
and we can do due diligence,
get you out to the factory?
Of course I'm going to get
a seat on the board, number one.
GUTIERREZ: Right.
Of course we're gonna go see
the factory,
and of course I'm gonna bring in
people that I trust,
that manufacture other things,
to help you guys.
Mm-hmm.
I-I'm not sure any
Of that stuff changes it. I-I --
So are you holding f-firm
at 25%,
or do you have room to move?
That's my offer. I-I'm not
interested in a counter at 15%.
Okay.
What are you gonna do?
All right.
So, Robert, would you take 20%?
[ laughs ]
No.
I-I -- You know, guys,
if it's worth --
If it's worth it to you
at 20%,
it's worth it to you at 25%.
$500,000 is a lot of money.
JOHN: Yeah.
That -- That's my offer.
I'm not trying to, you know,
negotiate you out of it.
I know.
That's the offer I feel
comfortable with.
Let's do it.
All right.
Well...
...we'd love to have you.
O'LEARY: Oh!
All right! Wow!
All right!
Excellent!
CUBAN:
Score one for the Robert.
Thanks, guys.
Yeah! Nice job.
Thank you. Thank you
very much. thank you.
Good job, guys. Well done.
Thank you.
CUBAN: Great product.
Great product.
Well presented.
Thank you.
Good job, Robert.
WILLIS:
We're pretty excited.
It feels like great validation
to just have Robert love
the product so much
and really have that
be the guiding force
behind his decision.
NARRATOR: In season 4,
Sabin lomac and Jim Tselikis
made a deal with Barbara
for their food-truck business,
Cousins Maine Lobster.
$55,000 for 15%.
Barbara,
welcome to the family.
Thank you.
Come on over here.
Come bring it here.
NARRATOR: Let's see
what they're up to now.
When we first came
on "Shark Tank,"
we had $150,000 in sales.
On our last update,
we had $700,000.
And now,
just a year later,
we're approaching
$3.5 million in sales.
What's cooking?
30 new applicants in Seattle.
When we started out,
it was our goal
to be the name and the face
of Maine lobster.
Right now we're taking
that step
with franchising
our trucks nationwide.
We are here today to deliver
our first truck
to our first
franchisee, Gil.
He loved our concept
and brand
and plans on taking the truck
to Phoenix, Arizona.
We have
a little surprise, too.
I'm excited. What?
[ horn honking ]
Look at this.
Hey, guys!
Barbara has always believed
that franchising our business
is the way
that we're gonna make it.
Wow.
Welcome aboard.
Running
a successful business
isn't just about keeping
all your profits and money.
It's about giving back.
So we created
our own foundation,
called Cousins for a Cause.
Welcome to Big Brothers
Big Sisters.
LOMAC: We chose Big Brothers
Big Sisters
to share
our profits with
because of
the personal connection
that I have
with their organization.
I was a little brother
growing up,
so the foundation means
a lot to me.
It was such a huge part
of my life growing up,
and now I have a little brother
named Lawrence.
LOMAC: What kind of theorem
is that?
Pythagorean theorem.
Phew! Boom!
Now I get to hopefully send him
in the right direction,
just like my Big Brother
did for me.
Whoo!
CORCORAN: These guys are
tomorrow's billionaires.
And more important than that,
they're gonna be
happy billionaires
because they know
how to give back.
What we have here
are two great entrepreneurs
that are giving back
and making a ton of money.
I mean, this is
the American dream.
Here we come, Phoenix.
We are so lucky to have made
a deal with Barbara.
Bottom line is,
she cares.
She's a part of our family,
and now we're a part of hers.
My name is Jayla Siciliano.
I'm from Solana Beach,
California,
and I'm the owner
of Bon Affair.
California is the perfect place
to start my business,
'cause it's the hub
of America's wine country,
and it's also the hub
of health and fitness,
which are two key aspects
to my product.
Cheers.
My past career involved
a lot of business trips
where there was a lot
of wining and dining,
and I needed something that
wouldn't pack on the calories
and wouldn't leave me feeling
groggy the next morning.
We have the sauvignon blanc
and the syrah.
Currently, my business
is a grind.
I'm doing everything
from store deliveries
to managing the website,
and it's really tough
to compete
with the big alcohol companies
out there.
We have the capacity to do
up to 10,000 cases
a month for you.
I've pretty much risked
everything
to start this business.
I quit my job,
I cashed in my 401(k),
ran up credit cards, and I even
went back to bartending nights
so I could work during the day.
If I don't get a deal
from the sharks,
I honestly don't know
what's gonna happen.
We're running out of money,
and we're looking
at possibly having
to close the doors
in a few months
if I don't get this investment,
so I have everything
on the line right now.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Jayla Siciliano,
and I'm the founder
of Bon Affair.
I'm looking for $150,000
for 35% of my company.
Okay, now, I'm gonna guess
that most of you sharks
like to drink wine
and also care about your health.
I'm one
of over 50 million Americans
who feels the same way,
and in my past career,
there were tons of dinners
and parties.
And I love to have fun,
but I couldn't afford to wake up
feeling groggy in the morning,
so I started adding soda water
to my wine.
But I found I could
socialize longer
and I would feel better
the next morning,
and that's when it hit me.
I knew this was needed
on the market,
so I quit my job,
and I decided to go for it,
and that's when Bon Affair
was born.
Bon affair is
the first premium wine spritzer
with California wine,
purified sparkling water,
and electrolytes,
with zero added sugar
and 6.5% alcohol.
I'd love to give you
some samples,
and I want to remind you
that this is not a replacement
for a full-bodied glass of wine.
This is a lighter alternative.
Think of it as the best
sparkling water ever,
'cause it has wine in it.
Are -- Are you okay
with that?
Thank you. Yeah.
CORCORAN: Thank you.
Cheers, Barbara.
To you.
Thank you. [ chuckles ]
whoa.
Thank you, thank you.
You're very welcome.
Toast. Kev.
Cheers.
HERJAVEC: Jayla,
if I ordered
a normal glass
of red wine,
your product,
how many calories?
So, this has half the calories
of regular wine.
What is the purpose of the
electrolytes that you mentioned?
You know, we make no claims.
It's alcohol.
It's not wheatgrass.
So we always say
the electrolytes are in there
'cause why not?
[ laughs ]
And from personal experience,
I find that they do help,
but interesting enough --
But help with what? I'm not sure
I understand the concept.
Um, countering the negative
effects of alcohol.
Less of a hangover.
Yeah.
Griffith University
in Australia
actually just did a study
at their health institute
on how electrolytes
added to beer
actually do hydrate you
more than regular beer.
Have you drank enough to really
test the -- the hypothesis?
I have.
Is anybody up here
a wine spritzer drinker?
'cause I'm not.
I am. Yeah.
How does it compare?
Um, it feels -- It tastes to me
less sweet than a spritzer.
Do men ever drink a spritzer?
I associate it with a woman.
Yeah, they do.
In the summertime --
No, they don't.
Yeah.
Yes, they do.
In the summertime, a rosé.
SICILIANO: They do.
Do they?
[ deep voice ]
Not real men.
Rosé wine with, um --
With ice in it
started in the South
of France in Saint-Tropez
back in the '50s.
It's now extremely popular
in North America.
Jayla, who is
the target customer?
So, the target customer
is a woman
who has a really busy
either career or she's a mom,
she likes to drink wine
at least a few days a week,
but she has to wake up
super early the next morning.
So she can drink your product,
not get a hangover.
She feels better
the next day,
but she's comfortable
in a social setting.
Yeah, it's kind of that
guilt-free option.
This is kind of like a skinny
margarita alternative, right?
Yep.
Right now we're selling
in 10 Whole Foods
from L.A. to San Diego.
We just went
into our first Albertsons.
We're approved to go
into three more Whole Foods,
and we're approved
for five more Albertsons.
Because you only have clearance
in California at this point.
Yeah.
And how much have you been
selling in those stores?
Um, we've sold about $11,000
in the last six weeks.
We just launched it.
[ groans ]
Oh, just --
This is brand-new.
You're six weeks old.
Brand-new.
Did you design this bottle?
I think -- I wouldn't mind
having a closer look.
But it's very elegant.
SICILIANO:
Do you want to see?
Is that your background?
Are you a designer of some sort?
Yeah, I did product development
and design
for footwear and bags
for seven years.
Thank you.
Looks very feminine.
HERJAVEC: Jayla, how much money
did you put into this?
I've personally
put in $30,000.
As I said, I quit my job,
and I've been doing
everything I possibly could
to make ends meet.
I went back to bartending.
And when I had
no resources left,
I ended up going out
and pitching investors.
Did you get
any investors?
I did.
I ended up getting $450,000.
Oh.
Whoa.
Wow.
From who?
From?
And we -- Um,
from two private investors
that I didn't know
beforehand.
Um, I got a $2.61 million
valuation on that first round.
[ laughs ]
I did. Hey.
You're
a pretty good salesman.
Maybe I'm a mini-sharkette.
No kidding.
[ laughs ]
And today you're asking
$150,000 for 35%.
So you're diluting
your original shareholders.
The whole company believes
a partnership with you guys
would be worth it.
Wow.
You -- You've run
out of money.
SICILIANO:
Let me explain what happened.
So basically,
we got that $450,000.
It was off to the races.
Let's go.
I had a bottler in Michigan
who had a really great
reputation at the time.
They bottled for --
Something must have
gone wrong.
It did.
It went very, very wrong.
Our initial production run,
we lost about 90% of it
due to leaky caps.
Why did it leak?
SICILIANO: They basically didn't
put them on there correctly.
It was very devastating,
obviously.
After all that,
our existing investors
actually put in
another $150,000.
How much money was lost
in that little faux pas?
We lost over $100,000
worth of inventory.
Oh!
So when they put in
another $150,000,
the -- the total
is still $450,000?
No, the total to date
is $700,000,
so they put in more,
our existing investors.
Whoa.
Our goal is to grow this.
We think there's potential for
an acquisition down the road.
You look at all the
coconut waters that
have been acquired...
[ laughs ] 'cause it's just
like coconut water, right?
...Skinnygirl margarita.
O'LEARY: Got to get
to $10 million.
Yeah, we'll --
$10 million in sales
to acquire.
I agree, yeah. Coconut water
wasn't there before.
I think this is
an amazing category.
It's just
the amount of money
you're -- that you're gonna
need for this is massive.
Jayla --
Well, there's lots
of beverages have --
That have grown out
their grassroots style.
And the benefit -- I mean,
we saw skinnygirl margarita
pave the path
for the low-calorie, but --
Very, very, very rare.
Hpnotiq, skinnygirl --
Very rare.
She had hundreds
of hours of television,
and she really hit a certain
audience that didn't expect it.
You can't touch this market
without even $5 million
to get started.
I know this journey --
Very, very hard,
and I've already lost my shirt
on one deal like this.
Daymond, you can help me
get those endorsers, though.
I-I couldn't help
myself.
Yeah.
I'm out.
Okay.
I don't understand
how you raised $700,000
from investors
for a value
Of $2.6 million,
and now, because I'm a wonderful
human being and a shark,
I get a value of $420,000
for the company.
Well, I know our sales
are low.
It doesn't add up for me.
It tells me that perhaps
there's bigger challenges.
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Jayla, who is
the number-one buyer
of wine in this country
on Earth?
Women?
No. Costco.
Oh. Costco, yeah.
Of course.
So, west
of the Mississippi,
there's one buyer
right here in California.
Mm-hmm.
Why don't you
go see her?
Costco? I would love to.
Yeah.
It took me a year to
get into Whole Foods,
and you guys could --
And she might listen to your
story and give you a test,
and it's only one buyer
for the largest buyer of wine
on Earth,
just one phone call.
No, I'm not opposed
To it at all. I think --
Kevin, are you gonna marry her
or make her an offer?
No, but I-I'm trying
to help her...
SICILIANO: Yeah.
...Because I'm in her business,
but I understand --
I think you could help me
get that meeting.
No, I know, but I-it's --
You know,
you're in --
You're in a difficult situation,
because you've taken down
a lot of investor dollars
to try and build a whole new
category in the wine business.
But I think you've got a lot --
A tough road ahead.
That's exactly
what you should do.
And I never give advice,
but I know this space very well.
Go do that, and good luck
to you. I'm out.
I am amazed
that you were able
to raise $700,000
from your investors.
It wasn't easy.
CORCORAN: Right.
You're an amazing salesperson,
truly,
but I really think you have
a double sell --
Sell the category,
sell the brand.
And I think it's gonna be
a heck of a long haul,
and it's gonna take
so much more money,
and I'm just not willing
to put that money in.
I'm out.
Okay.
Mark, I have put everything
I have into this.
I am laser-focused.
I am 100% dedicated.
I'm the most resourceful person
you'll come across.
What's the one thing
you need?
The one thing I need --
Exposure and contacts.
It took me, as I said, a year
to get into Whole Foods.
I know I'll get
a distributor.
I know I could get into Costco
if I really try.
But I know that with your help,
I could get there a lot faster.
Okay. I like you.
Um, I'm not an expert
in the wine business,
but I like the category.
I'll make you an offer.
I'll offer you
the $150,000...
...for 35%.
[ laughs ]
Mark, I will take it.
You are
a tough negotiator.
I am.
I'm tough as hell.
Thank you so much.
No problem. My pleasure.
I'm excited. My -- My wife
would love it, too.
I-I don't think Mark gets
The concept of "Shark Tank."
[ laughs ]
You take
small businesses,
and you make them
into big businesses.
That's the concept
of "Shark Tank," right?
You're so tough, Mark.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, all. Appreciate it.
Good luck.
Congratulations.
Being here today,
getting this opportunity,
and then getting a deal
with Mark makes me realize
every single day, every tear,
every struggle
has been totally worth it.
JOHN: You're gonna regret
that one, man.
We'll find out, right?
It's not like I'm spending
$10 million just as an option
on a big business.
If it works,
it's worth a lot of money.
If it doesn't,
I'm out time and 150k.
So the risk/reward
is enormous.
You know what?
Worst case, my wife gives
these away at Christmas.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah,
You're -- You're gonna have a
garage full of those things.
I know what we're getting
from Mark for Christmas, guys.
Bon Affair!
NARRATOR:
Next up is a treasure hunter
with a unique opportunity
for the sharks.
Ahoy, sharks.
My name is Mark Hargitt.
Okay, sharks,
here is the scuttlebutt.
I'm a treasure hunter,
and I found treasure.
I found 1,200 tons
of copper, silver, and gold ore
sitting in the belly
of the Mariposa,
a ship that sank
almost a hundred years ago
just off the coast of Alaska.
Let me take you there.
Wow.
As you can see,
there's a lot of kelp.
Pretty strong currents.
Going down the anchor line.
Got to hang on, because
the current will sweep you away.
And here's a steam valve.
You can see there's
a lot more artifacts.
Here's one of the fire bricks
from the boiler.
Wow. Very cool.
What was so cool
about that, Rob?
I just love diving
and treasure and --
That could have been a car
in the Hudson river.
[ laughter ]
So, Mark,
what is your offer?
I need $250,000 for 25%
of my business.
What do we get for that,
Mark?
Well, you'll get 25%
of, um, the booty.
The booty being that ore, the
rocks we were looking at there?
Well, there's more than that.
There is artifacts.
The wholesale value of the ore
I estimate
at around $2.4 million
if I can gather it all,
if I get the right equipment.
Mark, how did you find
the treasure?
Well, research
is the key there.
I'm a nautical
amateur historian.
I grew up
in the marine industry.
I'm the seventh son
of a seventh son
of a son of a son of a sailor.
Are you the only person
that knows
the GPS coordinates
of where it is?
Oh, heck no.
This is a well-known wreck.
Oh, it is?
Yeah, so why -- Yeah, so why
hasn't it been salvaged before?
Well, it has.
What gives you
the rights to it, Mark?
Well, I filed a claim
with the state of Alaska,
basically a mineral claim.
If it's been salvaged before,
how do we know with certainty
that the ore is still there?
Here it is.
What's that?
Come and look.
CORCORAN: Scared me
when you opened that.
Now, hold your breath.
I got some gloves here.
Oh!
This came --
Just came off the seafloor.
O'LEARY:
This is the ore?
No. This is
actually copper matte.
CORCORAN:
Phew! It stinks.
This is ore.
HERJAVEC: Why does it smell
so bad, Mark?
Well, because it was underwater
a few days ago.
Some of this is ore
that hasn't been smelted,
and some of this
already has.
What does that mean --
Smelted?
That means
it's concentrated.
So it's denser,
it's denser.
HERJAVEC:
So, Mark, let's say --
This is actually
a copper concentrate.
So you're assuming
there is "x" amount
of mineral down there?
Where else would it go?
Other people.
Plenty of things could have
Salvaged -- Other people
could have salvaged it.
Yes, they have, but they've
picked the cherries off.
They've gotten, like,
the ship's wheel,
and the whistle,
and propellers.
But do you think
the entire 1,200 tons
is still down there?
I don't see any reason
why not.
And how much
have you salvaged,
and what type of dollars
has that turned into?
Well, we have just salvaged
a few hundred pounds so far,
because we were doing it
by hand.
If I get three-quarters of it,
I'm thinking around
$2.4 million wholesale.
How long would it take to
salvage the entire mother lode?
I know with the eductor system
I want to build --
It's basically like
an underwater vacuum cleaner --
It would take about a week,
maybe two.
That's it? You could have
the entire mother lode up?
Well, that's
just a rough estimate.
What do you need
the money for?
Well, I need, uh,
equipment, crew.
Um, I need to build
an eductor system,
rent a barge, uh...
Sounds like you have
the equipment, though.
...Lawyers,
guns, shark repellent,
'cause there's real sharks
that swim around.
Sharks?
Yeah. There's real ones
that swim around.
O'LEARY: Okay, so, Mark,
if I want to invest
in treasure hunting,
there's many guys I can go to.
I'm gonna make that assumption.
O'LEARY: There's lots
of competitors.
Mm-hmm.
If I just started
to do my due diligence,
why am I picking you?
Well, because I'm the captain.
I'll do this operation.
I've been in salvage
all my life,
21 years
in the merchant marines.
I've saved ships.
I've had my life saved.
I've saved others.
This is, uh -- I'm the guy.
I can do this for you.
Good for you, Mark.
CORCORAN: Isn't there someone
in your industry
that you could easily go to
and get the money?
You're well known.
You have the experience.
Well, that is true.
You guys are plan "c," actually.
Plan "c"?
[ laughter ]
It's good
to know we're loved.
Well, plan "a"
is to do it by hand.
Plan "b" was to take
my early retirement.
I have half a million
in a retirement account.
Let me -- Let me just ask
this question.
You have the rights
for the minerals
on this ship, correct?
It was granted
exclusive --
Mineral rights, yes.
It was granted
exclusively to you,
which means you're the only one
who can go down there,
bring it up,
and sell it.
Since you have
the exclusive rights,
could you not simply take
your rights,
go to
a big salvage company,
and sell
your rights to them?
I hadn't thought of that.
Yeah, I could.
Welcome to
the Shark Tank.
Yes, yes. Great idea.
Mark, I get pitched this
all the time --
This treasure,
that treasure.
Everybody e-mail --
You do?
Do you really, Mark?
Oh, yeah. All the time.
There goes my lunch meeting
with you.
Oh, yeah. [ laughs ]
I've been pitched a lot
of treasure hunts.
Everybody talks
a grand plan,
but they never turn out
the way they project.
There's just too much risk
here, Mark.
I like you.
I like what you're doing.
You're a great guy.
But I'm out.
I'm falling in love with
the romance of the idea --
You know, diving deep,
salmon boats.
You know, maybe I get
into this investment,
I get my own patch
over my eye and --
Talk like a pirate?
Yeah.
And hang out with you.
Well, I do want you
to go diving on it with me.
I wouldn't have the slightest
idea what you're telling me
or what you're doing or --
I couldn't even advise.
I just -- I can't be of any help
here. I'm sorry. I'm out.
Well, you want to forget
about the money and just
sign on as crew?
There you go.
[ laughter ]
HERJAVEC: Like Daymond,
I love the water.
I love cars,
but I really love boats.
I've been a diver since I was
16 years old, padi certified.
In fact, I ran away from home
when I was 17.
I wanted to join the navy.
True story.
So I love it. Love diving.
Love everything about it.
Well, this is your chance
to go and take it
to the most moneymaking
adventure you've ever had
walk through these doors.
Arrr!
That's right.
But this really isn't
an investment today
I-I-in the kind where I can see
getting a return.
I'm out. Thank you
for coming here, though.
You bet.
CORCORAN: You know what the deal
lacks for me?
First of all, knowledge.
I have no knowledge of this.
I have to totally trust you.
When has that
ever stopped you before?
Yeah. But you know what?
It lacks the sex appeal.
I was hoping when you opened
that big box,
I was gonna see crown jewels,
some diamonds.
Well, it doesn't look like
a treasure chest. that's true.
CORCORAN: Somehow, seeing those
rocks just didn't do it for me.
I'm out. I just wish
it had more sex appeal.
I think that the only person
that's left is...Kevin.
O'LEARY: Very interesting.
First time we ever had
someone like you
in the Shark Tank.
I think there's
lots of risk in this.
It's, uh,
not a slam dunk at all.
It's just very expensive
to get it out.
No, not really.
Well, we don't know that yet.
Anyways, I --
Well, the system
that I want to use
is basically like an underwater
vacuum cleaner, an eductor.
I-I-I've actually seen it work
On a -- On a Roman ship
off the coast of Cyprus
that I got involved in,
and it's a long story,
but that ship now sits
in kyrenia castle.
It's very expensive. It takes
a lot longer than you think.
And that's in warm water
in the Mediterranean.
Here's the thing --
Once you start, you can't stop.
You got to finish it.
Otherwise, the whole
investment's worthless.
So, look, I'm not gonna take
the dive with you.
Good luck to you. I'm out.
Okay.
Good luck
with the treasure, Mark.
You bet. Thanks.
Well, you know, we've never had
an investment here
where one of the risk
is real sharks.
Do you know why they haven't
actually done that?
Because the cost
of taking it out is gonna
be more than $2 million.
That isn't cheap.
I mean, it's --
It's really expensive.
NARRATOR:
Next into the tank is a couple
with a twist
on a decadent dessert.
And my name
is Shannon Radke.
Thank you so much
for having us.
We're super excited
to be here.
Our company
is called Cinnaholic,
and we're looking
for a $200,000 investment
in return for 20%
of our company.
My background
in brand marketing
and with s-Shannon's talent
for baking,
we created the world's
best cinnamon-roll experience.
At Cinnaholic,
it's all about custom,
gourmet cinnamon rolls.
We start you off
with a fresh cinnamon roll
right out of the oven,
and then you can choose
from over 30 different
frosting flavors
and 30 different toppings
and create your own
very unique cinnamon roll.
Today, we have a couple rolls
prepared for you.
We're always hungry.
What do we have here?
So, for Robert, we're making
caramel banana cream pie.
You are speaking
my language, Shannon.
Thank you very much.
There you go.
And for Barbara, we're doing
our mocha almond roll.
Thank you very much.
There you go.
And for Kevin, we have
our classic old-school roll.
Oh!
It's vanilla frosting
with strawberry.
Shannon,
it's incredible.
Yay! Thank you!
And for Daymond, we are doing
our coffee cookie dough.
Wow!
Our cookie is
made in-house.
HERJAVEC: Mmm.
Isn't that amazing?
Bless me, Florian. Bless me.
Thank you.
Wow.
SHANNON:
And for Mark,
we have
our almond raspberry.
All right.
Thank you, Florian.
You're welcome.
Before I go on, how many
calories are in this?
Well, in our typical
old-school roll,
it's about 485, 500, depending
on the size of the roll.
In this?
Yeah.
Yes.
It's about half the calories
of our competitor.
All right, sharks,
we're here
because we need your investment
to open another location
and start
our cinnamon-roll empire.
So who's ready to make
a sweet deal with us?
Did you say
another location?
Yes.
Where is
your current location?
Our current location is
in Berkeley, California.
How many square feet?
It's about
650 square feet.
What are your sales
in that store?
The sales last year
were $260,000.
And before we go
into any more numbers,
there's a little, sweet secret
to our cinnamon rolls
that we haven't
disclosed yet.
There is a secret
to a cinnamon roll?
They're 100% dairy-free,
egg-free, cholesterol-free...
Unbelievable.
They taste the opposite.
Really?
...Allergy friendly,
and 100% vegan.
Yes.
No!
JOHN: Whoa.
There is
50 million Americans
that have
a dairy intolerance.
There is
another 5 million people
who have
severe food allergies,
and the top two are dairy
and eggs in children.
So we have tons of moms
coming in, and they ask,
"oh, my kid cannot have
any dairy or eggs.
Do we have anything
For them?"
we say, "yep.
Knock yourself out."
and out of the $260,000,
what did you net last year?
17%, so $45,000.
And you sell them
for like $4 apiece?
The average r-roll
is $5.50.
Is there another path
to big sales
besides more retail stores?
We went away from thinking
about wanting to go into retail,
like maybe having it
in Whole Foods or whatever,
because we think our product
is only that amazing
if you have the same experience
in the store.
Tell me what the $200,000
is gonna get me.
The $200,000 will get you
another store in San Francisco,
and then from there, we're
gonna go into franchising.
But you don't have
enough money
to go into franchising
at that point,
because you have to get
All the -- The legal documents.
You have to get
all the state approvals.
Costs another quarter
of a million.
Yeah. It's gonna cost
a lot of money to do that.
CORCORAN: Let me get back
to the food for a minute.
This was so delicious,
and it just dawned on me --
When did you make this?
Three days.
Three days ago.
It's three days old?
Yes.
You're feeding us this stuff
that tastes so good --
It's three days old?
Exactly.
Do you guys do anything online,
sell online at all?
We have a tiny, little,
small, online store,
just because we
have demand.
Hollywood celebrities
heard about us,
and they wanted
to order stuff,
so in order to fulfill that,
we just put it
like a small, little e-commerce
store online.
You're doing quite well.
The only thing,
getting back to your numbers,
is you've put a million-dollar
valuation on a single store.
It's a lot of buns.
And -- And so you're making
$45,000 for the investor.
That means you're asking
22 times your pretax profit
on a cinnamon-bun store.
The $1 million valuation
is on the brand
and on the concept.
We do believe that could be
a national food chain.
I don't think your business
model is that great
because of my experience
with cousins Maine lobster,
because on one food truck,
they're selling $800,000
a year.
What?
That's -- That's working.
CORCORAN: So, because I've been
spoiled rotten
by their first truck and now
their second truck, I'm out.
The challenge here is I want
to be in this space,
and I think I got
a little jealous
because of Barbara over here
with cousins lobster.
She's doing amazing.
The numbers
aren't there for me,
so I don't think
I can help you.
I'm out.
Okay.
This is so much like
wicked good cupcakes in Boston.
It's the same thing.
Here comes
a royalty deal.
a bloodsucking offer.
Silence, please.
A cupcake operator
in a retail location
decided to change the model
and go to shipping the product.
All of a sudden, they leveraged
themselves up 10,000%.
Their sales went from $15,000
a week to $300,000.
If people knew they could get
this overnighted to them
in a package of six,
it -- it -- you would get
a whole online business
that's extremely profitable
going,
and that may be more
lucrative than opening
up more retail space.
HERJAVEC:
Two problems for me.
One is the --
You're asking for $200,000.
You're gonna invest it all
into a second store,
and then it's gone.
If it works, we then have
to raise more money,
which is not a problem,
but then we try the franchise.
That's one challenge.
My other challenge is
you're valuing the business
at $1 million today.
I-I don't see the value today.
But I want to be involved.
So here's my idea.
All right.
I'll give you
the $200,000 for 40%,
but I don't want to do
another store.
I really like the idea
of putting them
in a nice, little package
and shipping them out.
I think he should pay me a
royalty for that idea right now.
[ laughter ]
I think people
are gonna go online.
We put all the investment
into that presence,
and now that's
a game changer.
All right. Is anything
you wanted to add?
I'm really contemplating
screwing up Robert's offer.
NARRATOR:
Two sharks are out.
Shannon and Florian have
an offer from Robert --
$200,000 for a 40% stake --
But Kevin is also interested.
I'm really contemplating
screwing up Robert's offer.
What I like
about my royalty program
is I don't take
any of your family's equity.
I don't steal 40%
like Robert's proposal.
He just takes
your family's legacy.
All right,
here's an offer for you.
Um, no equity whatsoever.
No, no, but wait.
Cover your neck.
$200-- $200,000.
Was that good? Huh?
Was it?
I also, uh, do not want to see
a second retail location.
You have to go
and actually --
My idea --
Uh, actually, I think
I brought that
to the table originally.
No, I think it was mine.
So, and my royalty
would be $1.20 a unit.
After I recoup my 200k,
it drops down to 60 cents.
In perpetuity
means forever.
But I've already proven
this model in wicked cupcakes.
It's wildly successful.
What are you gonna do,
Mark?
I'm gonna listen.
Do we have a chance to talk
about the switching...
HERJAVEC: Sure.
...The business model
real quick?
We'll be back
in one second.
Okay.
Yes.
All right.
Mark, I know exactly
what you're gonna do,
you little snake over there
on the corner.
What am I gonna do?
You're gonna come in,
listen to what they say,
and then give them a nickel more
and close the deal
and tell them they have
the 10-second clock.
Come on!
That's not
what I'm gonna do.
Oh, yeah?
You're gonna say
$250,000, 40%.
I will not give them
a full 10 seconds.
[ laughter ]
We really like your idea
of going into online shipping.
We know our product
ships well.
We don't really like...
You?
...Your business model.
O'LEARY: Think about it.
You'd rather sell 40%
of your equity instead forever.
Yeah, I -- Yes.
That's in perpetuity,
by the way.
Florian, I smell
a counteroffer coming.
I would love to be able
to negotiate with you
a little bit
if there is
a little wiggle room.
Um, maybe we can meet
at 35%.
Florian,
here's where I'm at.
I'm gonna say this at the risk
of Mark Cuban standing up
and saying,
"I'll take that deal."
[ laughter ]
You know it, too.
I'm -- I'm gonna stay at
the 40%, and I'll tell you why.
If it's worth 40%,
it's worth 35%.
It-it's a relative
small amount.
I mean, either we're
gonna be successful
in a big way together,
and I don't think the 5%
will make a difference.
Do you have anything
to add to it? nothing?
All right,
I-I think --
CORCORAN: Whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa. don't do that.
Don't lose --
D-don't lose the deal.
What are you gonna say?
Don't you dare
accept a deal when there's
something else on the table.
No. There -- There's
nothing on the table.
O'LEARY: There's nothing
on the table.
Yeah, bird in the hand.
There's nothing
on the table.
So, yeah, we would love
to work with you.
JOHN: All right.
Done.
CUBAN:
Way to go, Robert.
All right.
CORCORAN:
Ay, yi, yi.
Thank you.
Yeah.
You were
just about to lose it.
Awesome. Thanks, guys.
All right, awesome.
Thank you.
All right.
Congratulations.
You guys have a great night.
Thank you.
You're dead to me!
[ laughter ]
The exciting thing
about having Robert
as a partner
is having somebody
who is a serial entrepreneur
who knows
how to scale a business.
We started this business out
of passion for the business.
Now we have a partner who knows
how to blow things up.